sometimes i do feel pearly you talk on
behalf of men always more most of the
times
than women and you are a woman
and yeah it's great that you are seeing
their point of view and it's great you
know to point out you know what
just it should be for men as well and i
completely agree with that because we
are in the end of the day we are all
human people
doesn't mean you're if you're a man or a
woman for me we are all people and i
think everyone deserves to be respected
and be treated as the same
um but
most of the times what i
hear from your um
from your channels it's always like you
come from the men's side
you know and you are a woman and
sometimes you do comments based on women
that they are a bit
how would i say
um
low
okay so which comments like for example
there's a post recently that you post
and you said um about
fat women
the whales the whales yeah yeah so for
example
um if you were fat
i was fat
so yeah so let's say i met you when you
were fat
and i would call you a whale
i wouldn't do that because it's not my
person um i think everyone is a you know
is a human again and we have all
feelings
and my for example my mom she actually
got a bit of weight
because of medication there's a lot of
people they become the whales that you
call
that i don't
uh think that is right to call a woman
just because she's fat because it's post
depression partum you know or because of
medication or because of mental health
this is what we do and i think this is
what but we're doing it again you're
taking away accountability she's fat
because she ate too much when i was fat
it was because i ate too much and yeah
but there's a reason why people ate too
much probably because people bully other
people or probably depression or
probably they had
family problems in their house going on
and they cannot cope
it's a
mechanism
why weren't they like that in the 1950s
so so i'm saying people are fatter today
the people are the same but in the 1950s
they were thinner
why yeah why
there's more tv probably i don't know
yeah so a choice
and that's that's what it comes down to
that's a choice
if you're if you're fat that's a choice
it's a choice to eat more calories in
your burning i've been fat
okay and it was my choice and i and i
lost that was your case it doesn't mean
that everyone went through the same
experience as you because everyone went
through different experiences for
different reasons to get fat i mean to
you're looking for exceptions rather
than the rule like you're looking for
the exception most people are fat
because they eat too much
and don't exercise again yeah you have
to leave too so right and so when i say
what i was talking about in that post
was leaving the whales so if a girl i
was talking about if you if a girl gets
a ring okay and then she's 120 and she
decides to gain a hundred pounds to 220.
i said leave the whale because i'm sorry
you you made the choice to gain 100
pounds that's disrespectful to your
husband
and you know you you can disagree with
calling her a whale but like what else
you going to call her that's
and i know that this isn't the topic but
the one thing i've noticed about um
just the way that
the way pearl thinks and the way pearl
expresses herself is
not normal to
a regular woman because this is not how
we talk and so when i first met pearl
there were some things that she she was
saying
and then like as i've gotten to know her
and like seen her podcast and seen
everything i'm like this is this is
pearl she does not hold back she does
not um
she does not she just speaks it how it
is and how and how it is yes there are
some
some
things that she has said that may come
off offensive but that's how she is we
don't if a man was talking like this we
wouldn't be like oh this that in the
third because
that's how men are they just say it how
it is and so i'm not saying
that
i'm just saying that's how that's how
her opinion is and that's how that's
pearl and then you you have your own
opinion yeah but i'm not saying that i'm
not um i'm not respecting your opinion
that i don't agree with her
and she asked me an example and i said i
gave it to her and that's it i'm not i'm
not creating a beef i have nothing again
this is part of the podcast it's okay
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just saying i
just gave my opinion based on your
opinion you so my question for you do
you feel like i was incorrect do you
think a woman should be able to gain all
the weight she wants
not disrespectful i don't think women
they think i'm like oh my god i'm going
to eat so much today because i want to
become so fat but at some point nobody
does things that let themselves go when
they get there yeah like at some point
there's a point where it becomes a
choice like i'm not saying yeah
definitely that's like your body's gonna
my mom had seven kids she doesn't look
the same as she did when she was 22. but
the thing is she's always tried to stay
in shape the best she could and look
good for my dad so my whole point was
like it wasn't about the whale
although it kind of makes it funny or
she's laughing
some people
yeah like the point the point is that
like like men deserve to have standards
and so the whole point of my channel
isn't to [ __ ] on women it's to just talk
about like the unfair standards that
like men are held but there's a lot of
men as well after they get married
there's a big belly there huh
a lot of beard on the pub and even even
before they get married there is men out
there even young men i see these skinny
tall men like they you know
pregnant for five months and we ask oh
it's beer can i they're proud that's
nice
but a woman she's all sexy she's all
good she has a great body and we kind of
have like to be like forcing our
stomachs like when we sit when we see it
we have that to force ourselves to not
show any fat otherwise we're gonna be
judged you are too fat or you're to this
or you're skinny or too that so women
are more punished
uh by other women and men
oh how they look but men they can have a
big [ __ ] nose like [ __ ] a [ __ ]
bridge eyes hot
eyes
or having a big belly no no no no no no
i i observe a lot i am not i observe a
lot because you probably women and men
are judged i observe a lot i'm gonna
tell you that women and men are judged
on different categories
so so like a man can be overweight and
unattractive but if he makes enough
money a woman will overlook it yeah i
could be you know rich off this podcast
tomorrow not every man with a big belly
is like doing monies oh no i know but
like sometimes sometimes we wish uh he
they wish
anyway but yeah i'm just saying the the
men
they even before marriage or after
marriage
they don't care either there's men out
there they don't care either okay i was
all for equality of leaving yeah i was
offered both ways because i feel like we
we have to understand that a
relationship
uh even though it should be based on
love initially like
your partner is an extension of yourself
and
they rep they're like an ambassador for
you you know what i mean and you're an
ambassador for them so it's like if you
truly respect your partner you want to
make them look good and therefore you
will take care of yourself like
and if your partner starts to let
themselves go then
you have to be like hey like you know
we're not looking good here like
i mean this is especially true for like
celebrity couples and stuff but even
people who are not in the public eye
like it's just something to be realistic
about and you know a lot of people might
say like oh that's superficial or
whatever but like we do
like superficiality is a part of life
like it shouldn't be the whole basis of
your relationship but like
i don't feel like true love means that
you can just love yourself by any like
shape or size you know what i mean
because it's like
it's important to look after yourself
yeah because essentially if you are
if you are overweight and
not able to do daily things in life
you're not going to be able to do the
things you need to do for yourself one
but also for your partner in your
relationship because
of your health your health is like
number one for everything because if
your health isn't in check and your
health isn't in order you're not going
to be able to be a
functioning human being
and i think that's something that people
forget when they say hey you're you're
unhealthy how dare you say that to me
like no like we want you to be healthy
we want you to be able to
be a human and operate
correctly to instead of being unhealthy
and having setbacks and you're not the
best version like
you know how you are like when you're
insecure about your body like you're the
worst version of yourself like i i am
the nicest person when i feel skinny let
me like like i am the nicest kindest
like you can't say [ __ ] to me when i
feel skinny
but it's like when like and i've had
guys where they'll say i'm still
attracted to the big girls but i won't
date them because they're just
exhausting because they're so insecure
all the time yeah that's so true but
there's a lot of women they have great
bodies and they still have insecurities
as well
yeah everyone has insecurities you know
yeah i mean those the guys i talked that
i've talked to about this just say
there's more when you're bigger which i
think kind of makes sense there's a lot
of guys as well they like big
it's just i think they say again
they settle for big they don't they
don't like it
they just settle for it like any find me
a movie star that's dating a lizzo
like a guy there's another oh what's her
name uh the blonde one she's very she's
very funny she's an actress no humor but
she's not that strange no no i'm talking
about that i find me uh
find me a guy that has a ton of options
that's like
hot that that is good money has all this
stuff going for him
and find me a guy like that that picked
a girl that's big yeah she might have a
big bum but yes
big boobs big bomb
just like if a girl looks like a model
like typically she goes for a rich guy
successful
or tall like it's just you know that's
what it is
yeah yeah i have a question for you
pearl because
i mean i i agree with a lot of things
that you say and
i admire how you sometimes like give
facts that don't necessarily favor you
and my question is like how do you
cope with for example i hate the
statistic like i know that it's true but
i hate it
the one that um
men find like men of all ages find women
from 18 to 24 more attractive which by
the way i've read the other half of that
um of that study which states that even
though
men of all ages find women between 18
and 24 more attractive they would
actually rather have a relationship with
a woman that's closer to their age but
either way like um
you're 25 right
so like when you see statistics like
that like how how do you deal with like
the the feelings that come up of like oh
[ __ ] like you know what i mean like oh
it bothers me i don't enjoy it like it's
not fun i don't enjoy that like it's
like we don't tend to get better looking
with age but i like the way i deal with
it is you can't do anything about it you
look how you look and it's really just
comparison like you're how old are you
23 23 oh oh wow okay so you're in that
category i mean
just about to leave it but yeah but like
i mean you're you're more attractive
than most girls like i like that's how i
recruit for the show no i seriously like
i pick i pick girls that i think are
pretty and i like or guys that are like
because it's entertainment like i get
better views the better looking the
girls are and so you're still going to
probably be more attractive than most
girls even at 30. like you'll just be a
little less attractive than you are now
but
i mean i think i think the point is like
you just want to find a husband because
once you have a husband who cares yeah
like the only person that needs to find
you attractive is your husband sure and
again i just deal with it like
i can't do it i can't get younger so all
i can do is date the best like the most
intentionally i can
um try to get in the best shape that i
can because if you're in good shape
you're still in the top like 25 of women
in the u.s probably more here you guys
aren't as fat but
but like like what else are you supposed
to do but i think it's just when you are
making like the choices to date as
intentionally as you can like you feel a
lot better about yourself because you're
not like wasting time yeah like i felt
so much better when i broke up with my
last boyfriend because i was like okay
i'm not i'm not wasting my time anymore
and it's like less you know like yeah
you could be married in a year you never
know
please it's not good does that answer
jesus is like me i'm walking away from
today thinking oh my god i need to like
find someone quick 21's got somebody
i've got 25's gone
same i'm like you look great i can't
believe you're in your room you're gonna
like to start lying i will give you 25.
max 24 34 give it to you that's the
attractive
at the attractive range what was it
to me it's like to me it's like these
facts are hard to hear at first but when
you have all the information and you
like because again i've the reason i can
talk like this is because i've heard it
all
but like oh my gosh if you watch my old
reaction videos guys i'd watch some i'd
be like
the wall what's the wall
you guys
it's complex
that's a whole nother conversation but
but you just start to get like okay this
is the bed this is like at least i know
now and i can you know date more
intentionally now rather than later
yeah that's like based on reality and
not like some some fantasy doesn't
happen
rather than wake up at 40 and be like
where's my high value man